am. My name Julius Mur. I'm an
accountant by profession
and I have one question. It's on Quran
39:29.
>> Brother, can you stand close to the
microphone?
>> And can you repeat your name and your
question? I could not hear it.
>> Okay. My name's Julius Mur.
>> Julius.
>> Yes. I'm an accountant by profession and
I have one question on Quran 39:29.
which is all about
uh Allah.
On the last comment he made
uh praise be to Allah.
What does this uh brother is the Quran?
Which reference you to give?
>> Pardon?
>> Quran. What is the reference you give?
>> 39:29.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. What does it say you're saying?
>> He praises himself on the last comment.
What the what does it say?
>> It says Allah presents an example a
slave owned by owned by correling
partners and another belonging exclusive
to one man. Are they equal in
comparison?
Price be to other. Why does uh God
praise himself?
Oh, there is there another God in that
question. Allah subhana wa tala gives
the example in surah a chapter number 39
verse number 29. Allah is giving example
that would you prefer a slave who's
owned by quarreling partners. A slave
who has many partners, one slave
belonging to many masters or quarreling
or would you prefer a slave which has
only one master
which is better giving example of those
who do shik and those who believe in
Allah is giving a comparison
that can you believe that one person can
have many gods or would you prefer only
believing in one god? Would you believe
in many gods which are quarreling? You
know we have in some religion you have
god of rain, god of sun, god of clouds
and one god fighting with the other god,
one god defeating the other god or would
you prefer believing in a religion which
has got only one all powerful god. Which
would you believe?
one Allah is saying praise be to God
means praise be to Allah who only one
Allah
regarding why as Allah us praising him
the reason Allah is praising him is
Allah subhananahu wa ta'ala knows the
human nature
that when we praise someone we follow
him by praising Allah Allah does not
become better for example if you say
Allah
Allah is the greatest it does not make
Allah greater Allah is already the
greatest whether you tell 10 times or 20
times or don't say it may no different
but when we say Allah is the greatest we
tend to follow Allah when we praise
alhamdulillah we tend to follow him for
example if your mother has a heart
problem
and you know this doctor is the best
heart specialist he's very famous world
famous will you follow his advice or
will you follow an advice of an unknown
man who whose advice will you follow?
The heart specialist is famous. So the
moment we praise Allah, he's all wise,
he's all knowing, we tend to follow his
advice. So Allah praises himself in the
Quran. So that when we read, we tend to
follow him. Here is the example Allah is
giving between a slave who has got many
partners who are calling among
themselves or slave who has one partner.
So if you follow Islam, there is one God
all powerful. If you follow other
religion, one god fighting with the
other god, one god defeating the other
god, one god hiring a third god to kill
the first god. All this is there
confusion. So Allah is giving an example
and telling you that's the reason you
should accept the one true god. Got the
answer brother? Do you believe there is
one god?
>> Do you believe there is one god?
>> Yes. Do you believe Jesus is God or
Jesus is the messenger of God?
>> He's the messenger according to
>> he's messenger of God or he's God.
>> He's the messenger of God.
>> Jesus Christ is a messenger of what?
Good.
>> Do you believe that Prophet Muhammad is
the messenger of God?
>> Yes.
>> Mashallah. So brother, I'm very happy
because to enter Islam, you require
minimum two things. Minimum. Number one,
believe that there's one God which you
always believe. Number two, you have to
believe that Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger of God which you always
believe. So according to me, you're a
Muslim.
According to me, you're a Muslim. So
you're happy to be a Muslim.
>> Uh
>> are you happy to be a Muslim?
>> Okay. Right now.
>> Can you on the microphone?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. right now I think uh
it's time inshallah maybe
>> mashallah you believe in Allah
>> dude one thing brother once you believe
you should not delay I don't know how
long I'm going to live I don't know
whether I live tomorrow I may go today
in the car I may have an accident I may
die so if I do something good AGREED
BECAUSE TOMORROW IF I can do it tomorrow
and today if I die what will happen so
if Do you agree? If you believe there's
one God, if you believe Jesus is God, if
you believe Prophet Muhammad IS THE LAST
AND FINAL MESSENGER, YOU ALREADY A
MUSLIM.
CORRECT? Would you like to say it in
Arabic? Correct. Would you like TO SAY
IT IN ARABIC?
In Arabic, same thing that there's one
God and Prophet Muhammad is a messenger.
>> I can say it.
>> I can say it and you can repeat it.
Okay. What?
>> Are you ready to say it in Arabic that
you believe there's one God Muhammad's
messenger?
>> No problem.
>> Okay, I'll say it.
>> Okay.
Allah Allahill
>> Muhammad
>> Abdulu
>> Abdul
>> I bear witness
>> that there is no god but Allah
>> I bear no god but Allah
>> and prophet Muhammad
>> is the messenger
>> and servant
and a servant
>> and so
>> servant
>> of Allah
>> mashallah you're a Muslim
>> I would like to thank
>> Takbir
>> I would like to tell you brother that
you have entered the family of two
billion Muslims once you accept Islam
all your previous sins have been
forgiven
all what good you do remains whatever
wrong you did is washed away. I pray to
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala to give you
the best in this world and the I would
like you to read the translation of the
Quran and understand Islam better so
that you can practice Islam better.
Okay.
May Allah reward you. Thank you very
much.